amazon.com whole foods and starbucks
use pricing techniques to gouge their
customers
he sheds light on these and other
economic enigmas
in the undercover economist this talk
from the american enterprise institute
in washington d.c
is an hour 20 minutes
my name is bob hahn and uh
with the help of bob lyden from
brookings i helped
run something called the aei brookings
joint center
for short or if you're interested in
long names it's the aei
brookings joint center for regulatory
studies
i'd like to spend a minute or two
talking about what we do and how we do
it
and then i'm going to uh
turn things over to this person who has
no name who goes by the name of the
undercover
economist first i'd like to
thank my right hand person sasha
gentling
for helping to put on this fabulous
event
and sasha does a great job
and if you are interested in being kept
abreast of joint center events in the
future
feel free to fill out the blue card that
you can find
in the folder six years
ago we started the aei brookings joint
center
as a way of trying to hold legislators
and regulators
more accountable for the policies that
they make here
in our nation's capital we try to
achieve that
objective in a number of ways
but one of them is through issuing
publications so for example last year
sam peltzman wrote a book on regulation
and the natural progress of opulence
where he talked about
how he thought regulation would evolve
over time
the year before that we were very
pleased to have
justice stephen breyer write a book
about economic analysis and judicial
reasoning
where he talked about the possibility of
using experts
in judicial hearings independent experts
as a way of sifting through the minutia
that we sometimes have to sift through
as analysts
perhaps to make it easier for the judge
to make a decision in complicated
hearings uh this year we were very
pleased to
uh have professor william bammel of
princeton and nyu give a talk
uh which basically explained why every
thing you learned in econ 101 may need
to be turned on its head for some kinds
of markets we deal with
and indeed our featured speaker tim
harford
addresses some of those markets in his
book
for those of you who are interested all
of our
downloads can be freely
downloaded all of our books and articles
can be freely downloaded
from our website which is in that
powerpoint it's www.aei
hyphenbrookings.org and i assure you
that
i do not get a cut
we are here to discuss today um
well i should add that another one of
our functions
is to try to hold events
uh where we can make either economics
or the policy game in washington more
accessible
to folks both who are here and outside
the beltway
and that's essentially the purpose of
today's event
we are here to envy
tim harford for having such a fantastic
cover
for this book the undercover economist
just on the cover basis of the cover
alone
i'd urge you to buy this book
some time ago for those of you who are
rock and roll fanatics
you may remember that fleetwood mac did
a song
entitled you make loving fun which was a
big hit
as i recall well while reading
tim harford's exquisite new book i
couldn't help but think that if tim has
a testimonial dinner and i think he's a
bit young for that
the banner might read you make economics
fun if i only had this book
when i was an undergraduate at brown
university more years ago
than i care to acknowledge my interest
in economics
would have been peaked considerably
who would have thought that the arrow de
bruy results on general equilibrium
theory and don't worry if you don't know
what i'm talking about tim will be happy
to explain it in english
who would have thought that anybody
could make a snap out of explaining two
nobel laureate theorems
by distinguished scholars but tim does
it in this book
i have a strategy to suggest to you for
for digesting this book no pun intended
i suggest you go down to your local
starbucks and buy
a cup of coffee then think about
what that transaction means for you
and the world if you get a latte with an
extra twist and by the way i don't drink
coffee
so if i don't if i say something wrong
don't worry about it but if you get a
latte with an extra twist
you may be one of those folks who's
willing to pay a bit more
to show your status or just to feel good
but is it really the starbucks
shareholders
who benefit from your purchase or is it
the guy who manages the starbucks
or is it the lady who happens to be
serving you behind the counter
and why does starbucks charge different
prices anyway
and why can starbucks charge those
prices
well you can read the book and find out
or you can come to today's seminar and
hopefully enjoy what i hope will be a
fun-filled hour
if this book were just about starbucks
then it might still be a good read
but i think it's about a lot more
tim tackles healthcare in about five
pages as i recall
providing a very elegant economic
solution to a difficult problem
what's the solution basically charge
folks
for routine day-to-day things like
getting a bottle of aspirin
but make sure that everybody has
insurance for the things we really need
it for
like catastrophic events even if the
government
has to intervene in the course of 200
pages he explains how we should address
environmental issues why globalization
is mostly good and why some countries
are growing like weeds
in parentheses you might read china and
others
continue to stagnate at its heart
the lesson from this book is the lesson
of economics
we need to learn how to devise
institutions
perhaps the marketplace that will get
the incentives right
that will enable us to have the kind of
economic growth
we want and prosperity that i think
we can achieve speaking of
uh incentives i'm sure that the more
perceptive of you have noticed
and i hope this appears in tyler cowan's
blog tomorrow
that we are providing you with a free
lunch
free water and free access to the
restrooms
most importantly so our undercover
economist
might ask what's in it for us
well i hesitate to say this because my
boss may be listening or may see this
later on c-span
but we're not really in the business of
making money here i know
that might strain that might sound
strange i do get a salary of sorts but
we're not really in the business
of making money we're in the business
we're in the public policy business
we're in the ideas business we're trying
to disseminate
our thoughts be they great or otherwise
and in the best of all worlds we're
trying to separate
truth from falsehood
let me say one or two uh words about
the ground rules for today and then i'm
going to
turn it over to our featured speaker
tim's going to speak for about 20
minutes and then i've asked our
distinguished discussants
who i who i hope to embarrass shortly
and they are tyler cowan and sebastian
maliby
i've asked our distinguished discussants
to talk
for about 10 minutes besides writing
books
tim harford writes a dear economist
column for the financial times
mr harford taught economics at oxford
university
was a scenario expert for shell and i'm
waiting for him to explain to us what a
scenario expert does
because i may hope to become one and he
also
works at the international finance
corporation so without any further ado
i'd like you to join me in welcoming
tim harford thank you
wow thank you very much bob thank you
um i want to start actually
can you get this on tv brawny white pack
of 8.
um i'm actually not going to i'm not
going to start by talking about this but
i just wanted to
you know it's the elephant in the room
people have been looking at me strangely
ever since they've seen this
uh i'm going to talk about my favorite
restaurant first
put that there don't touch it bob um
so so my favorite restaurant the i mean
this is a great place
uh the wine list is amazing the food is
wonderful
he's soft soft meatballs
a puddle of polenta fantastic
pasta it's done to perfection you could
have a great steak there
great roast it's absolutely terrific and
it's cheap
it only cost me eight or nine bucks for
lunch there and then you know i have a
glass of wine that's three bucks more
it's absolutely fantastic value
there's only one problem the problem is
uh
the barman now the barman is the rudest
man i've ever met in my life
uh the the barman he has these tattoos
i can't really show you because well you
know he's not built like me he's not
really built like
normal men um my friend tells me he got
the tattoos in a russian prison and
whenever he
sees me coming there's this sort of
i said two please
then later on he'll bring the menu
i'll look at the menu the food is great
menu is cheap
i'm being embarrassed with my date but
you know it's still very nice
i order the food
guy walks off i order coffee get him
coffee
the guy is the worst waiter in existence
so
maybe this restaurant just hired
you know a bad member of staff but i
read a review
of the restaurant that was written two
years ago
that i identified a completely different
member of staff a woman and i
swear this this person was never a woman
i don't know what they can do in
hospitals this day but this person was
never a woman
and um and said well you know the the
food is great the polenta and the steak
and everything but the
the bartender acts like she just came
back from a tax audit
so so my sense is there's there's
something deliberate going on here
there's an
actual policy to have you know really
very rude stuff i'm trying to work out
what it is
this is the kind of thing i like to do
in my book you know think about my
personal problems and then talk about
them with everybody else
and you know i i think i know what the
solution is
the solution is this i'm eating in the
bar
it's fine the tables are fine the food
is great the food is cheap
there's a restaurant behind the bar that
will charge me
fifty dollars for an entree
now they're covered in white tablecloths
but the food is really no different
so how can they just justify charging me
10 bucks and everybody behind the bar
in the main restaurant 50 and i think
the answer is
the guys in the main restaurant aren't
going to be bullied by
a guy who got his tattoos in a russian
prison
but other than that we're using the same
kitchen it's very very simple if i'm on
an expense account lunch
or if i'm on a really nice date i i will
pay
it didn't work out with this one anyway
i
i'll pay good money simply not to be
embarrassed and then to enjoy this great
food but if i'm just going
out with with colleagues and if i'm
paying with my own money
i will i'll take the pain of dealing
with this man
just to enjoy the food you know because
i don't want to pay 40
just not to have somebody be rude to me
and
you know this this sort of tactic is
actually surprisingly common you would
think that nobody
could stay in business if they were
actually hired people to
you know deliberately be rude to their
customers nobody could stay in business
if they deliberately
ruined products but actually it makes
perfect sense if you're trying to target
some of your products at people who
don't care what the product costs
and some of your products are people who
do care what the product cost but
the product is basically the same it
costs a lot to make the product
different
so the product will tend to be the same
well
in that case you're going to have to
just find a way to persuade the people
who are willing to pay 50
that they don't want to pay 10 and in
this particular case
you know the answer is igor the the
russian bomber
and actually
here's when we come to these uh this
kitchen towel
actually i bought this on uh on monday
and uh then my wife broke you know broke
it open and started using it so i had to
buy another one on tuesday and then
tuesday evening my wife came home and
she saw you know 15
uh kitchen rolls she thought i
completely lost it and maybe she's right
but not for this reason
um this this costs five dollars
okay this is eight kitchen rolls if i
want to buy three kitchen rolls i have
to pay nearly four dollars
right so the the last five kitchen rolls
are nearly free
the question is why and the answer is
this is substantially less convenient
uh i mean i could break it into two i
mean maybe bob you know you could pay me
a dollar 25 for two
and tyler dollar 25 for these two
sebastian 1.25 for these two and i could
have the two here
and we're all ahead on the deal
but i don't see any takers so it's just
a way
of spoiling the product to make sure
that people who really care about the
price will go through the inconvenience
of carrying this thing around
and people who don't care about the
price will just grab a roll of two
and in case you think that you know
these are just extreme examples
you want to know what this is this is a
paperback edition of the undercover
economist
now there's no reason why you shouldn't
be able to read this today but you won't
be able to read it today you won't be
able to read it for another year or two
now if that's not deliberately ruining a
product i don't know what it is
what is what is the point of releasing
the paperback edition
so late yeah i'm gonna have to do all
these talks which it's a pleasure of
course
uh the radio appearances try all the
advertising all the
all the marketing and then in a couple
of years we're going to have to do it
all over again
they deliberately spoiled the product by
releasing it later than when the
interest
interest really is and they've done so
at substantial cost to themselves
and the answer the question is why and
the answer is because it's worth it
because you can split
your customers into two just a little
bit of everyday life
and there's one more example
you want to know what that is has anyone
ever seen one of those before
from starbucks thank you very much
spoken like an expert this is an
eight-ounce cappuccino
now officially you can't get an
eight-ounce cappuccino in starbucks it's
not on the menu
twelve ounces is the smallest you can
get uh now i called starbucks i said why
don't you tell them that you serve an
eight ounce cappuccino
they said oh there's no room on the menu
so i checked the website there's plenty
of room on the website
but it's not on the website either but
you go into any starbucks in america and
ask for a short cappuccino
they know exactly what you're asking for
they have the cup
they'll serve you the cappuccino they'll
charge you less and the cappuccino
is better this is officially approved
well kind of officially approved
by the world barista championships who
specified that the ideal size of a
cappuccino
i kid you not the ideal size of a
cappuccino
is about six ounces so this is a this is
a better cup of coffee when it gets bits
you know explained it to me it gets
bigger the foam kind of collapses you
get that sort of
you know kids bubble bath effect it's
not really not really very nice but
you know an eight ounce cappuccino is
pretty close to optimal it's a better
drink and it's cheaper
and now you all know to go and buy it
the question is
why don't they advertise it well the
answer is
well because it's so good and it's cheap
they don't make a lot of money when they
sell these things they don't want you to
buy it
they they want to make it available
because they know there are a few
customers like me
who will suggest that you know i go to
starbucks with some friends and then
i'll
get one of these things they don't make
money off me but they make money off my
friends
they make a little bit of money off me
it's better than not having me in the
in the store at all but they don't want
to offer the opportunity
to you know the the masses the bovine
hordes out there who are just drinking
the
the 20 ounce cappuccino i mean a 20
ounce cappuccino is a contradiction in
terms it's not a cappuccino guys
it's not a cappuccino at 20 ounces
anyway the
they don't want to advertise because
they make a lot more money on the
20-ounce cappuccino and they don't want
people to trade down
enough advertising for starbucks um
let me tell you a little bit about this
this
company and their um the incredible
power they hold over us
oh no when i leave my apartment building
in the morning the first thing i see is
a starbucks
you know and i walk along p street
there's there's another starbucks there
dupont circle i can turn south
down connecticut there's another
starbucks and then there's another
starbucks and there's a starbucks
at farragut west if i take the metro and
then there's another starbucks outside
my office
doesn't this strike you as a tremendous
example of corporate power
not this is a sign of corporate
desperation
let me tell you who has power the dmv
have power
the department of motor vehicles there's
only one department of motor vehicles
you know if i have a problem with my
license i don't go down to the corner i
don't have a dmv in my building i don't
have a dmv over my office
the dmv don't come to you you go to the
dmv now that
is power starbucks do not have power
starbucks are desperate
to get you to buy their coffee and so is
any retailer in a competitive market and
that's why they're everywhere that's
that's the sign of desperation that's
like the
the ex-boyfriend who keeps phoning you
up you know that sort of availability
that's not a sign of power uh
and i i i argue in my book that
it suggests to me and it varies from
from one company to another and you know
you can go through the accounts if you
like but i don't because
they're boring it suggests to me that
a company so reliant on real estate
is not necessarily making a lot of money
because the people who really have the
scarce resources
are not starbucks they are the
landowners who own scarce property the
people who own that nice
little corner spot on the dupont circle
they're the guys who own the uh
the intersections of the streets and the
avenues in manhattan
those are the guys who have power so
should i take the cappuccino away should
we keep the cappuccino there i want to
talk about the cappuccino a little more
you know there's no one in the world who
knows how to make one of these things
nobody i mean how would you start first
you need milk
you know how to raise a cow you know how
to grow grass
bob how are you with milking great yeah
good i'm not so good myself i
i get confused between the male cows and
the female cows it's it's not
it's not pretty and um you know and
you've got to grow the coffee
you know how to grow coffee i know i can
grow tomatoes i don't know how to grow
coffee so tomatoes
sorry i don't know how to go grow coffee
i don't know how to grind coffee you
need to generate electricity
i'm not good with the electricity
generation stuff that's difficult for me
then when you need us you need steel for
the for the um
espresso machine and water you need to
know how to purify water
uh i mean well that means you need to
know how to build pipes forget it
this is an impossibly complicated
problem there's no one in the world
knows how to make a cappuccino and yet
you go down to starbucks they'll have
you a cappuccino it's
it's really not a problem so
the way that the free market puts
together
all of this incredible complexity
carries out all its coordination and
delivers you the cappuccino the short
cappuccino the cheap one by the way
uh this isn't this is a a miracle it's
as though there was a sort of
supercomputer that was taking in uh all
of the desires that people had all of
the information about the costs of
of milking the cow and the costs of
growing the coffee and the cost of
shipping the coffee and the cost of
generating the electricity
the cost of hiring the barista and the
costs of
hiring the land to put the starbucks in
the
free market takes all of that and your
desires and makes it into a cappuccino
and that's incredible and that
supercomputer is is constantly
recalculating it's
impossibly complicated so that if for
instance
there's a a frost in brazil
there's a frost in brazil so that kills
coffee beans that means there are fewer
coffee beans to come to market
that means the price spikes higher that
means that if you are
growing coffee in say kenya or tanzania
you'll get a better price for your
coffee if you get a better price for
your coffee then suddenly you have a
windfall and then
well that would mean you probably want
to spend it and you probably want to
spend it on
some kind of capital investment maybe a
nice tin roof for your
house but that means that the price of
tin roofs would go up
so then ideally you might want to find
some kind of savings product so you
could save the money
to incredibly complicated it's
completely impossible
for any one person or any one
institution
to carry out all these calculations but
the market can and in fact
i mean this sounds like i just you know
pull the example out of the air but
there's a piece of work done a few years
ago by some researchers at the imf that
actually tracked the response to a
frost in brazil in tanzania where the
government
took the price risk and the government
had to make the decisions about what to
do
and in kenya where the farmers took the
price price whisk and the farmers had to
make the decisions about what to do and
it turns out in kenya
the farmers identified this was a
temporary price spike identified that
they should be spending it on capital
goods which means
tin roofs for the for their houses
identified the fact that the price of
tin roofs was uh
inflating worked out that they should
delay their purchases smoothed out the
price of tin
carried all this out needless to say
since we are in the aei i probably don't
need to point this out the government of
tanzania didn't manage to do
quite so well but other than that
reflects particularly badly on the
government of tanzania because they're
competing against an impossible
opponent this free market supercomputer
in my book
i i say the market when the market is
working well
and i should say it doesn't always work
well there's plenty of instances where
it doesn't work well and i talk about
them
but when it when it's working well it's
generating
true signals you know it's we're living
in a world of truth
when markets are competitive where we as
consumers
in our buying patterns are communicating
the truth about what we really want
and companies are communicating the
truth about what things really cost
the underlying cost the cost of that
electricity the cost of that coffee
so it's a little bit like the jim carrey
film have you seen it liar liar
this is this is a film where um he's a
lawyer
and his uh his son wishes that um just
for one day
he would tell the truth it turns out
that when his son is making this wish
he's
sleeping with a senior partner at the
law firm she turns to him and says well
how was it for you he says
i've had better so
this this film is to me is like
is like the free market you go into
starbucks
in a world of lies and and they'll say
well you know how much you want to pay
for the coffee and
well you know this i don't really i
don't really want coffee actually maybe
you should just give me the coffee for
free
and starbucks well the coffee is very
very expensive you know
all this all this waste all these all
these mistaken decisions
in a competitive market starbucks are
operating in a
somewhat competitive market um you go in
and
uh you know they can find out they can
find out how much you're willing to pay
you know they can charge you five
dollars ten dollars twenty dollars
they'll see if you pay it
they're free to do that at the same time
you're free to walk out the door and
find somewhere cheaper
competition between these different
coffee chains is pushing prices down
closer to the costs and yet the truth
comes out
i'm willing to pay 2.50 for one of these
things i'm not willing to pay 2.80 for a
bigger one
starbucks costs are lower than 2.50 for
one of these so they're happy to sell it
to me so the truth emerges
i think that was the thing about the
arrow de bruy theorem don't use words
like
theorem just you scare my readers away
bob
um sometimes the
truth that markets generate is painful
now sometimes we don't want to face up
to the truth so
at the moment uh you've got the oil
company executives
up on capitol hill being grilled as to
why they decided to put prices up
presumably i hope they're going to ask
them why they decided to put them down
again
but what's the truth the truth is
hurricane rita and hurricane katrina
destroyed vital aspects of america's
energy infrastructure
and so there's not enough gasoline for
everybody to drive like they used to
drive
so somebody has to stop driving please
and then we have to work out
who's going to stop driving and it's
going to be the people the people who
are willing to pay three dollars a
gallon for gasoline
uh and still drive they're not the ones
who are going to stop driving
the people are going to stop driving are
the ones who are not willing to pay
three dollars
a gallon for gasoline that's the truth
and that's an unpleasant truth it's a
truth that politicians don't want to
face up to it's a truth that
columnists and and commentators don't
want to face up to but there you go
there are also things that government
can do to alter those truths
government can basically tell lies
through the tax system through subsidies
now i argue that this is not always a
bad thing you know i mean
well jim carrey discovered that it's not
always a good idea to tell the truth
right and we don't always want the truth
that the market gives us sometimes we'd
prefer a white lie
sometimes the white lie is affordable i
make a few suggestions in my book
you know there's nothing there's nothing
sacred about the truth but
it is worth knowing when we mess around
with free markets
what it is that we are trying to do
let me um tell you a story
about uh somewhere that doesn't have
very uh very good markets cameroon
beautiful country in africa i
i went to see a library in cameroon and
um the the library was part of
a very nice school near the town of
bermenda
and the library was designed to hold all
of the schools books
and of course cameroon has a rainy
season
rains solidly for five months so
naturally
the architect considered wouldn't it be
a nice idea
if the roof of the library was designed
to look like a book
and there look the rain would fall on
the library roof and drain away
except he decided it should be that kind
of book
when i went into the library there
weren't any books there um
the uh it was four years old at the time
uh
the plaster was falling off the walls it
had a sort of smell that reminded me of
some um byzantine architecture i'd been
to in greece that was over 800 years old
some sort of
musty cavey sort of smell in a
four-year-old building that's designed
to hold books
i also saw the books the books were in
the school's existing library
school's existing library is fine it's
bigger than
it needs to be to hold all the books it
includes space for the children to study
and it's waterproof the question is why
did the librarian why did the principal
of the school decide that she wanted to
build this library that didn't work
the answer is she didn't have to face
the truth she
wanted to make a statement she wanted a
university
the school to be upgraded into a
university she wanted a grand library
with a grand roof for sort of poor man's
sydney opera house
there was no particular oversight of the
way she was spending money
she was getting money from old boys of
the school i think she was getting some
money from the government i don't know
if she was getting money from donors i
i hope not um no one was really checking
how she was spending the money
none of the teachers in the school were
in a position to protest about how she
was spending the money because
they could be fired like that there's no
there's no due process
she didn't really mind whether the
library worked or not because it wasn't
designed to hold books it was designed
to get her a university
so you have a country where people are
spending money
without any consideration of process
without any checks and bounces on them
from the top
from the bottom and even the
the parents of the school kids are not
going to complain because they know
well they want the school to be
prestigious they also know that the
quality of the education the children
receive doesn't make that much
difference in cameroon because the jobs
are not handed out because you've got a
good education
the jobs are handed out based on who you
know
i talk a little bit about why poor
countries are poor
when it comes down to it it i believe
that poor countries are poor because of
a whole
collection of bad decisions they're
based around
things like
this library and it's not because
anybody is evil anybody is stupid
in poor countries it's because the evil
stupid people in rich countries get
called to account
at least sometimes and the evil stupid
people in poor countries don't get
called to account often enough so that
in a nutshell is my account of why poor
countries are poor
i hope that's given a sense that the
book is not just about uh
cheap cappuccino and eight packs of
kitchen rolls
but i did want to read you
one uh the last paragraph of the book
because i think that
this stuff is important actually
it's about china in 2003
yang li did what many chinese workers
have done she left home to work in a
sweatshop in the pearl river delta
a month later after working 13-hour
shifts
she decided to go home and start her own
business a hair salon
every day at the factory was just work
work work she says
my life here is comfortable
yangly's parents had to survive the
cultural revolution her grandparents
had to survive the great leap forward
yang li
has real choices she lives in a country
where those choices
mean something for her quality of life
she tried factory work
she decided it wasn't for her now she
says
i can close the salon whenever i want
and for me economics isn't just fun
it's about yang lee's choice thanks very
much
i was looking for a distinguished
economist to uh
to comment on this and i can think of no
one better than my friend and colleague
tyler cowan who's a professor at george
mason university
tyler writes on all sorts of strange and
interesting
subjects and maybe he'll tell you a
little bit about his forthcoming
forays into the food business and
understanding
food professor cowan
directs the mercado center and the
buchanan center for political economy at
george mason
he's also professor in the department of
economics he's written several books
including creative destruction how
globalization
is changing the world's cultures and
uh he's also one of the leading econo
bloggers and i commend his site to you
if you're interested
in getting educated and a unique
perspective
on economics marginal revolution.com
so without any further ado tyler
first the big picture this book is the
best introduction to economic reasoning
that i know of
bar none so i'm a big fan of tim his
column
and his book and i think it's it's more
original than sometimes he lets on
what strikes me about the book most of
all is not just the economics but tim's
britishness
and i often like to approach books
through biography
if i compare this to american writings
on the economic way of thinking
consider gary becker or david friedman
or steve landsberg
it's so american if i may say and
there's something about how tim
visualizes economics there's a kind of
of modesty and self-effacingness and
humor
that in the book there's an overall
vision as to how the economic way of
thinking
fits into human life and the notion of
having a good life
and being a human being that i think is
quite original and quite unique
and maybe most of the reviews won't pick
up on but that to me is the most
striking thing about the book
and what i found most interesting
reading it now as commentator i take it
as my duty to some extent to disagree
with tim
and i've read the book twice and i agree
with almost all of it but there are two
particular points i disagree with
so let me talk about each of briefly the
first point has to do with health
insurance
tim's recipe for health care as i
understand it
to encourage people to pay for their own
health care for small items
but give them government supplied or
government subsidized catastrophic
health insurance
for large items uh my view of the matter
is that people are extremely
risk-averse or law diverse concerning
their health even for small expenditures
and that it's ultimately a futile
endeavor to try to change the tax code
or subsidies or policy to get people
away from the health insurance model
my view is closest to that of arnold
cling which is that
third-party payments are inevitable
ultimately they're a good thing
health care costs will indeed balloon
but all things being said it's the best
thing we can spend our money on
when it comes to catastrophic care
i wouldn't in any way want to tax
catastrophic care
if only for liberty concerns but i'm not
convinced by tim's view that we should
be subsidizing it
if we were to look only at efficiency
not my view but if we look only at
efficiency
my sense is actually we should be taxing
catastrophic care
to some extent and the money would yield
a higher return simply as pure wealth or
prevention
or better lifestyle exercise or diet but
just looking at health quad health
subsidizing catastrophic care is
probably not the way to go
the other example or argument of tim's i
disagree with it really comes on the
first page of his book
and he mentioned it in remarks and
that's the starbucks discussion
and the coffee and i take tim's argument
to be something like the following
that they're starbucks you go in you pay
a lot of money for a cappuccino
or whatever you buy most of it's water
most of it isn't coffee it's actually
most of it's sugar and cream once you
get past the water
and tim's argument is that the landlord
ultimately
is earning that money back in the form
of rent
and that coffee shops don't make that
much money it's a kind of rent
to location and that that's why you're
paying so much above marginal cost when
you go to starbucks
uh my detective work on that phenomenon
is a little different
if we go to starbucks or comparable
doors typically we find
large markups on some items and much
smaller markups on other items
so for instance a cd in starbucks might
not cost that much
relative to a cd at a low rent tower
record store
or relative to low rent amazon.com
i did an experiment this week with tim's
own book i checked the price of it
at the high rent borders on k street on
my walk over here
and i checked the price of it at the low
rent borders at bailly's crossroads in
that's virginia illegal immigrants go to
buy fake driver's licenses bailly's
crossroads
and it's this it's the same price in
both places so my gut feeling is that
to understand markups while rents are
relevant
we shouldn't start with the idea of rent
but we should start with what i would
call the idea of decor
i think of decor in the case of a
starbucks it's what the store looks like
more broadly it's the image of the store
in the media it's the self-image you
have is some kind of cool latte drinker
maybe you like being surrounded by
bearded people wasting five hours
blogging on their laptops
but starbucks has a certain decor which
is quite distinct from the rent it pays
and imagine that you have an equilibrium
where a lot of different coffee
suppliers
or potential coffee suppliers are
complete competing to supply the decor
that customers want
and most of them fail they'll spend a
lot of money on a decor plan and it will
fall flat
but some small number of those
businesses or stores will succeed
and they will come up with the decor in
the broadest sense that consumers want
and those stores will have the decor the
value of that decor
will end up exceeding the rents they pay
or the prices for their land
and because they have the desired decor
they draw a lot of people in the door
those people are then willing to pay an
excess marginal cost for the drinks they
buy
i think of this is quite similar to
music markets in music markets as a
whole it's extremely competitive there
are not excess profits
but people try to produce different
kinds of good music
if you end up being the beatles you have
enormous excess profits ex post
you're providing a kind of decor with
the music that people want to buy
so in tim's analysis the value of
starbucks as i understand it is captured
by the landlord
that to me doesn't square with reality
that starbucks is incredibly profitable
had i bought at the ipo
my sense is i'd be a very wealthy man
today so i think of the rents not as
being captured by the landlords
but being captured by the people who
develop the decor
and that of course would be the original
starbucks shareholders
and those who got in early another way
to think about this distinction between
rent and decor
is to realize some other cases where
rent and decor do not fully coincide
so if you go into a restaurant it's well
known that there is a markup
when you buy drinks that the markup on
wine might be a factor of three
three and a half uh coca-cola costs them
very little to bring it to you you might
have to pay 250 or three dollars
but if you look at rural restaurants
restaurants with fine decor
but low rents in rural areas rural
france rural america rural new zealand
there's still a very high markup on the
drinks and this to me again suggests
that the markup
on the drinks is linked to decor more
than to rent per se
and uh the decor hypothesis also
predicts
that the cheap items in a restaurant
will have the highest markups so if your
restaurant or coffee shop has great
decor
people will want to come just for the
decor they might want to buy something
by just a little
go into a fancy restaurant and order a
mineral water
and see what happens what do they do to
prevent this well maybe they have rude
waders
but one thing they will do is on the
cheapest items they will have especially
high markups and those will be drinks
and we find it's also the case that
appetizers tend to have higher
percentage markups than domain entrees
which have the lowest markups and this
again would be a consistent with the
hypothesis
that the markups are determined by decor
and reaped by the original shareholders
rather than stemming from rent tim's
book is extraordinarily stimulating
there's something to think about
literally on every page it's well
written
it has a mood it has a feel it's about
policy it's about your everyday lives
it's about what you eat
it's about what it means to be british
i recommend it highly i liked it better
the second time i read it
i've blogged extensively on it and i
will use it again
with that i'll close my remarks and
thank you tim for writing the book
i hadn't realized uh this was
quintessentially british when i asked
our next speaker sebastian maliby who is
a distinguished journalist
who's written on problems on both sides
of the atlantic
as as well as the rest of the world to
join us
sebastian maliby is currently a
washington post columnist
and a member of the editorial board
prior to that he worked for the
economist
magazine and i think that's where we
first met as the washington bureau chief
chief and he wrote the lexington column
on american politics and foreign policy
he has wide-ranging interests and i will
just touch the surface here they
they include globalization international
development
and u.s economic policy including even
occasionally i would say regulation
based on an occasional phone call i get
mr maliby as many of you know has
authored a number of articles
in leading newspapers and journals other
than the washington post or i should say
in addition to the post
and he is also author of the world's
banker a history of the world bank
under james wolfensohn and he too has
a unique or dare i say uncanny ability
to
boil down complex ideas into
a form that they can be readily
explained at the dinner table
so with that i turn it over to you
thanks bob
when i began in journalism after leaving
oxford
where tim taught he didn't teach when i
was there i'm older than him i think but
we shared that background i went to the
economist and
one of the first things i was told was
that you know the writing style should
be such that you're speaking to somebody
where you assume great intelligence but
no knowledge
you assume a willingness to absorb ideas
if they express simply but you don't
presuppose that they know the specifics
and i think this is the principle that
tim has put to work in this
really appealing book which
by being so well written has kind of
skirted around
what i think is otherwise the
inescapable problem of this kind of book
which is who are you really pitching it
to
um you're banned in this kind of book to
be explaining things which are reader
some of them
will you know some readers will know
quite a lot of these concepts already
some will know rather a few of them
most readers will be in between so how
do you avoid boring the poor reader
when you're explaining something like
you know the random walk theory of
efficient stock markets
if that reader already knows it well the
answer is you do it in a light
intelligent way as if you're sitting
over a cappuccino
having a talk with a friend and
explaining it to
him in sort of simple language uh in an
unpompous
way and so there's always this light and
intelligent touch
um which means that even when you
already know what you're being told you
sort of don't mind being told it anyway
because it's so well put
and you sort of try and store in the
back of your mind uh these uh
linguistic tricks uh for possible uh
recycling later
uh at least that was that was my
response to it so um in this chapter for
example
about this one chapter in there about uh
how
markets work how the technology bubble
was inflated there is stuff about you
know what a p e ratio is and
you know the stuff about the random walk
theory and
some readers will know that already but
they won't be bored by it and there may
even be things in the same chapter which
they haven't thought about i for example
i don't think i'd ever thought so
clearly as tim had
about the proposition that technological
change in the country
can produce lots of economic growth but
not necessarily produce
any extra profits at all in fact it
might well reduce profits because of
course
one of the um premises of all the
bullish talk in the late 90s about
the internet bubble was that you know
new technology therefore growth
therefore profits well as tim shows very
clearly
the last step doesn't really necessarily
hold
you only get extra profits if you've got
extra
scarcity that a company controls
and the scarcity or the barriers to
entry may actually diminish not increase
with the advent of a technology like the
internet and all of this is put
very well with some nice historical
examples there's a
an anecdote about a bet that tim lost i
think
with another economist where his friend
said
if you had bought stock in the great
western railway company
in the 19th century britain which turned
out to be the most successful of all the
railway builders
you would not have made more than 10 a
year
um because there were plenty of other
railway companies
that were also building lines and
even though there's note that britain's
economic takeoff in the 19th century
had a lot to do with railways there is
quite a lot of reasons to suppose that
the
stockholders of those companies didn't
necessarily pocket the benefit
uh and then tim in his undercover
sleuthish kind of way
put his sherlock holmes hat on and went
and looked at old copies of the
economist
and came up with the answer that yes
indeed
he lost the bet and returns were i think
something around five percent
uh or thereabouts in this company
um so that's just one example of how
sort of you know the
miraculous lightness of being that you
can you can get away with
explaining basic ideas uh if you do it
well enough and with enough
wit and elegance um
there are great um sort of uh real-life
examples i think the principle of the
book is
you know don't have an abstract example
if three funny everyday life once would
do
and we've already heard quite a lot
about cappuccinos as a as a father
of an 11 year old boy who's sort of
curious about some of this stuff i
i can't wait to the weekend where i'm
going to take him off to starbucks and
buy him a
mocha and then point out that i know i
buy him a hot chocolate probably
and then i'll point out that the the
cappuccino uh
cost uh two whatever 255 and two
let's say 225 the hot chocolate was 255
but if you combine them together and
make a mocha it's 275 now how did
combining the two
suddenly jack the price up well it's
this principle that
if you just uh try it on and you offer
some customers who aren't willing to be
tricked the lower price option so you
don't lose them
hey why not charge the people willing to
pay for the marker uh
an extra 20 uh or 30 cents um
and so it it it it gives sort of it's
it's a good uh you know i mean
whether you use it on your 11 year old
or on your
buddy from work it's up to you but um i
i
i do think it's fun to be able to apply
these concepts to everyday life but
there are lots of other examples
one had to do with the way that did you
know that
the difference between microsoft xp uh
window uh the sort of home version the
professional version and
if this particular case is true but in
most of these versions apparently
uh the professional more expensive
version of software is made first
and then an extra step is taken
afterwards to disable the
cheap version do you disable a few
functions on it
and you sell the thing that you spent
more time messing around with for less
and again it's just a way of seeing if
you can persuade some people to pay the
extra
and if there's some people you know
aren't willing to pay the extra you
don't lose them all together by having
the alternative product down below did
you know that uh
um there was a i think one one company
made a printer i forget which company it
was
and there were two versions of this
printer and one was the expensive luxury
version and the other one was a cheap
basic version
the only difference with the cheap
version was that it had an extra chip
inserted into it afterwards to slow it
down
again a good example of trying to create
products at different
uh pricing points in the market and all
while
learning about these sort of funny
everyday examples you get
the kind of quick history of uh how
david ricardo moved from uh writing
about these ideas
uh to going into politics and doing
something about them and
so the historical and theoretical is
match sort of woven in with the everyday
uh in this in this very appealing manner
now
um yes i'm supposed to criticize i
suppose and although there isn't
a um a really uh uh
uh serious criticism i can think of i'll
think of one completely unserious one
and one
uh moderately more serious um the the
unserious one is that sometimes you know
of course one wants to argue that it's a
great public service to write this sort
of book you know you tell everybody how
all these
market mechanisms work public policy in
the long run will be better off if the
public is better informed
but sometimes i find myself wondering
well you know if we actually explain to
everybody who owns a house
you know in an inner city that building
commuter rail
to the suburbs is going to drive their
real estate prices down
reduce their wealth because the scarcity
value of living in the city as opposed
to in the suburbs has just been
reduced this will absolutely kill you
know what little public constituents
there is for its irrational public
infrastructure
so there might be some perverse outcomes
to um spreading wisdom in this
absolutely promiscuous way that tim has
set about doing
um the other point though is that
um you know i'll invoke here a second
um piece of uh advice to economist
writers joining
uh as i did uh whatever nearly 20 years
ago
uh and uh what was a sort of famous
deputy editor of the economist who
who'd reigned over the paper for a long
time used to sleep on the floor when
he'd had an
intense writing day in a sleeping bag
and kind of get up and fire in the
morning and carry on
and and norman mcrae who was was largely
unintelligible because he had this thick
scottish accent we sometimes tower over
people and say
boy understand simplify
exaggerate and uh
this was the principle of writing good
economist pieces now
don't let you know don't let the sort of
the qualification
um always hold you down
you know go for it if there is a basic
truth there make sure the reader gets it
don't be afraid of stating it
in a compelling way and this is
certainly the tim harford principle and
so it does
turn out that sometimes uh some of the
assertions
could have been qualified now
one such example i think has already
been raised on on on health care and i
think it's actually true that there is
some research done by
at rand as i recall showing that
um you know if you make people pay for
everyday care they consume less of it
but they consume less of the needed
sensible preventive
care just as much as consume less of the
less necessary going to the doctor for a
cough kind of care
um so there are there are some sort of
you know little
footnotes that one could add to that one
but that's already been done in a better
way than i can do it
by tyler so i'll move on to another one
um
there was a passing reference in in
tim's book to the effect that
the great thing about economics it only
tells you about how cappuccinos are
priced
but they also tell you about why poor
countries are poor and which countries
are rich and what you can do about it
well um having written a book about the
world bank recently uh
an institution which has tried to apply
the sum total of human economic wisdom
uh to the question of how you make poor
countries richer i wouldn't be
quite that uh blithe about it myself i
think there's some evidence that um
extremely smart economists have applied
the best wisdom possible and
it didn't always work out um but still
well
we'll leave that one aside and uh maybe
another one
on the question for example of uh
immigration
um you know tim argues from first
principles in his uh
sleuth you know sherlock holmes hat kind
of way
then of course if you import uh lots of
low-skilled workers from outside the
country will drive the
uh returns to skills uh to to low-skill
labor
down and so the indigenous native-born
american workers will
if they are without college education uh
have lower wages as a result
and if you flick through his footnotes
you see that george borges the harvard
economist who's most associated with
this argument
is duly cited but there is actually
another school of thought on this david
card of berkeley as
perhaps some of you know uh has written
on the same issue has produced a
different form of
econometric measurement approach uh
which shows that in fact
uh in cities where you have high
immigration of low-skilled workers
and then if you compare those with
cities which have a low immigration of
the same kind of workers
and you compare the effect on native
wages
you don't actually see any effect on the
wages of low-skilled americans so there
is this
wrinkle shall we say in the literature
and last time i checked in with
um some of the best labor economists in
the country to kind of get an
adjudication of this debate
it seemed that for that at that point
anyway um
the uh the the david carr berkeley
argument had slightly the upper hand
um but so this is all to say um not that
um
this isn't at the end of the day a
criticism because i think that
you know you the the greater danger in
life
uh is uh not seeing um
the bigger picture uh for all the detail
and what tim is doing and has done
extremely well is to equip people
with the intellectual tools to be able
to analyze
a situation to figure out what probably
is going on
that hypothesis will need to be checked
empirically but lots of empirics is not
what this book was about it wasn't what
the book should be about
and it would have been an unreadable
term if it had been about that
so as as a contribution to
the hypothesis formation function i
think he could not have done a better
job
so congratulations
we're going to open it up now for a q a
and if you could raise your hand we'll
identify you and if you could identify
yourself and address your question
to your favorite panelist or all of the
panelists
and if you could stand up too please hi
i'm will wilkinson from the cato
institute i had a question for
tyler about the decor rent dispute
uh is it isn't uh isn't uh
locations which are part of rent part of
the decor
oh sure sure absolutely but
rent in decor even in long run
equilibrium are not identical
because you have many different firms
competing to supply the appropriate
decor and most of them fail
a few hit it big and then get somewhat
dominant positions like starbucks have
and those rents are exhausted by the
competition but exposed when starbucks
sells the drinks
price is going to be well above marginal
cost and starbucks uh will be a very
profitable company
but maybe i should let him address this
also
i have a point about dave there are two
there are two separate issues here so
one is
um uh does starbucks have some sort of
scarcity power
uh that it can exploit with these
various pricing strategies that we've
discussed
cheaper cds more expensive coffee you
know the mocha
the cappuccino the short cappuccino um
or
you know does a restaurant have scarcity
power that it can exploit
by say setting up a bar with a rude
barman and then
charging markups on certain types of
drinks
and the answer is yes and then so and
you know we can talk about
what those strategies are and i do and
that's fun and then the second question
is
where does the scarcity power come from
does the scarcity power come from the
fact that
they made a lucky gamble they happened
to choose the right decor
and they can now churn that out and uh
and keep going for a long time until
someone is able to perfectly copy the
decor without being sued
which is tyler's view or did it come
from
uh actually the scarcity power is not
inherent in
starbucks at all it's something they
have to rent uh
from their location uh and i'm sure you
know
this is a little tedious i'm sure we're
both kind of right and the question is
going to be about the about the
distribution
i and i am quite sure that starbucks
have
some market power directly from their
decor directly from their brand
that other companies are not able to
copy oh so i will certainly can see that
to tyler
i still believe though that if uh the
starbucks
uh contribution was was really that uh
powerful
they just wouldn't need there just
wouldn't need to be so many starbucks
frank
they wouldn't need to be so you know
wretchedly convenient
and the great restaurants that if you
read
tyler's blog marginal revolution which
you you should because it's excellent
you will see tyler traveling hundreds of
miles
uh and soliciting advice and you know
he'll fly to texas to say oh here i am
in texas does anybody know any good
barbecue in texas i would you know go
anywhere
i mean he doesn't just write about bbq
he writes about economics too
but this is
what i don't what i don't see is is is
tyler
being willing to you know travel across
the continents to sample
a starbucks because of the great decor
so it seems to me that you know it is
partly location
you want to respond or tyler you're okay
yes hi my name is jared petrovicis i'm a
recent graduate in economics from the
university of michigan
and my question is for mr harford um
you mentioned that we always don't want
to hear the truth in terms of prices in
terms of taxes and subsidies
and i was wondering if your book
addresses government's role in kind of
disguising the truths and
where their line lies in essence free
markets how free the market should be
so here's an example um in
this is a very common issue in the uk
but i think
presumably you know north the north us
as well every winter we get a big bunch
of old people dying of cold
and this is not regarded as being a good
thing
and so and i tend to agree i'm not in
favor of that
um okay but it's
but i mean this is a true recollection
of the situation these people are quite
poor
uh fuel is fairly expensive
uh the houses are difficult to heat
they're not very well insulated and so
it's hard to stay warm
so the truth is you know a lot of them
are going to die
um i don't think that we have to accept
that as being a final
verdict of the market but there are
there are better and worse
lies to tell now we can say okay the
truth is these people are poor but
you know we could make them richer we
could we could give them money to spend
that they could spend on heating
or you know we could which is the
situation in britain
we could reduce taxes on fuel so that
it's cheaper to heat houses
now for me the correct response is to
find people who are suffering from what
we call fuel poverty and give them money
should we tend not to give them money we
tend to give them free insulation or
vouchers but money would seem to do the
trick i mean they might want to spend it
on moving to florida rather than
insulating their home or heating it but
you know they'll work out what to do
with it
um it doesn't seem to me that a good way
of changing the market is to try to
basically uh lower taxes which you know
so
failing to reflect all the the scarce
resources the externality costs of
of some kinds of fuel etc whereby
everybody gets cheap fuel whereby nobody
has any
incentive to insulate their house and
people build these huge houses and
don't worry about it seems to me that
there are there are good and bad ways
to to change these unpalatable truths
hi uh nick gillespie with reason uh
tim's book
kind of testifies to an interest a
general interest in economics and
a book like freakonomics which is on the
bestseller list
also does histories of economic ideas
like the commanding heights did very
well
i'm interested if the panelists do you
think there's a generally higher level
of economic sophistication
among typical voters today as well as
policy makers
and then what real effect what does that
have on how policy gets set
in the wake of katrina there were really
very few calls for
um you know rationing gasoline for
instance in a way that 30 years ago the
same thing happened something
something would have happened yet at the
same time everybody knows that certain
type of government spending is
inefficient
but we have the biggest increases in uh
government
biggest increases in government spending
since lbj are actually
surpassing lbj so is there more economic
sophistication and then does that
translate into better policy
i mean one obvious point is that the
difference between the 70s and now
in terms of responding to an oil shock
is
at least as much in the elites as in
you know the general public i mean in
the 70s
belief in controlling prices i mean we
hadn't had a stagflation experience
before
um and you know the the charge of wage
price controls as i remember was was led
by the chairman of the fed at the time
so it was there was elites
going for this as much as the general
public so
one response
i would agree with sebastian i don't
think the public necessarily is more
economically literate
i think a few key leaders are in some
ways which don't always rebound to our
advantage they're better at exploiting
the laffer curve
and instituting vote maximizing
interventions which
sometimes coincide with wealth
maximization but don't necessarily
i i don't think that free economics
has contributed to economic literacy and
i don't regard that as a criticism
because i'm sure
that if you uh told steve levitton steve
dubner that
um you know that should be the aim of
their book they would be horrified
but i do think that it may indirectly
contribute to literacy because it's
created an
appetite for fun economics and the sense
that actually this can be fun
my concern has been that up until now
the best popular economics writing has
still tended to be very
much you know banging the lectern free
markets are good free markets are good
you know get the government away
and yeah i mean free markets are good
but this isn't very much fun
to read okay so people turn off because
it's boring
now for economics doesn't talk about
markets at all as far as i can work out
and it's really interesting
i hope that my book has a little bit
more policy relevance but i i sincerely
hope it doesn't have too much policy
relevance because then it would be very
dull
and i i'm sure that
uh economists are now falling over
themselves to get books out in the wake
of
free economics my my book was written
before free economics it's a it's a
happy coincidence for me
but i'm sure i won't be the last person
to publish a popular economics book
you know now that free economics has
shown that it can be done
and i'm sure that that will help for
sure because we know there's one
way of getting people to learn and
that's making stuff fun
thank you i'm albert kyle an economist
at the carnegie endowment for
international peace and i've done a lot
of teaching graduates and undergraduates
and a lot of work in china and also in
africa and so
this book is very interesting if it can
really help people understand economics
and
motivate them motivate them to study it
further
could you elaborate a little bit more on
how you make interesting
uh the failures of markets
uh and and you've alluded to it in this
winter tale of northern england but
i i sense that the notion that taxes are
a lie
is a characterization of something
that's done about market failures
and yet there is a whole subtext in the
discipline
the theory of the second best and
efforts to try to integrate power
relationships into the way
developing countries really work or
don't work and i wonder how your book
can make those very important truths
understandable and appreciated by
an audience that's just experimenting
with the discipline
well one example is where i
explain that um congestion is a bit like
a drunken frat party
um so we used to we used to have these
parties at
uh at oxford and i'm sure sebastian
never
you know degraded himself by
participating in this kind of thing but
the kind of people i hang around with
um so you'd go to the party and the way
it would work is you'd pay say
15 obviously it was pounds but
i'm just translating okay if we paid 15
for a ticket and then there'd be
unlimited booze so
people would and you could pay 10 and
and not drink any alcohol and just drink
orange juice but the orange juice wasn't
very nice
and to be honest a party where a lot of
people are binging on unlimited booze
you don't want to be sober so
basically everybody would pay the 15 and
then they would just drink and drink and
drink
and i argue that well this is a bit like
the way that the roads work
it's actually quite expensive to get on
the roads you have to pay your your
road tax your license charge you have to
buy a car
various taxes you know inherent in the
car um
but once you actually get on the roads
the roads are free
and so you get pretty much the same
result that you got at the parties which
that you know
at the parties everybody drank far too
much and you know everyone had a
miserable time
and if they'd actually just been charged
by the drink then everyone would have
been a little bit more sensible
and in um it's the same thing with the
roads if people actually charged
i'm not in favor of charging drivers
more but i am in favor of charging
drivers
to drive rather than you know to to
enter the class of drivers and then be
able to drive
as much as you like for free so this is
about congestion this is about
externalities this is a clear market
failure
um i have a whole a whole chapter in the
book about externalities
and i argue for road pricing we've done
it in london it's worked tremendously
well
so uh maybe i shouldn't say this at the
aei but i
for sure believe that markets you know
often fail and
but i'm in favor of sensible ways of
dealing with that failure
there is another market failure um i
just want to
tell you about um
here here is uh
the opening of jerome k jerome's three
men in a boat
so mr jerome goes to uh goes to the
british museum and he
and he's reading a medical dictionary so
i came to typhoid fever
read the symptoms discovered that i had
typhoid fever
must have had it for months without
knowing it wonder what else i had got
turned up some fighters dance found as i
expected that i had that too
began to get interested in my case i
determined to sift it to the bottom so i
started alphabetically read up ag you
learned that i was sickening for it the
acute stage would commence in about
fortnight bright's disease i was
believed to find i had only in a
modified form
and so as far as that were concerned i
might live for years
cholera i had with severe complications
diphtheria i seem to have been born with
i plodded conscientiously through the 26
letters and the only malady i could
conclude i had not got
was housemaid's knee i then
say if you were mr jerome what would you
do
he decided to take a trip up the river
my advice as an economist would be
immediately to purchase himself
some very expensive generous health
insurance
so i also talk about how health
insurance markets don't work adverse
selection problems
uh so i'm by no means fully in favor of
markets and say
let them rip they always tell the truth
everything is wonderful there are market
failures in the world and
and uh i just think we have to deal with
them sensibly
we have time for one or two more
questions then i'm going to ask our
panelists
if they'd like to say any concluding
remarks anyone else have a
question
i have a question about who to ask you
who do you think has a responsibility to
explain
better to the american public or other
publics
about deficits people seem to understand
how to run
their own household that some years they
can
spend more than they make but then they
have to pay it back
over some other period but it seems for
the federal deficit
the solution people think is reasonable
is cut it in half just overspend half as
much
five years from now as we as we're
spending now
is it something the media should be
doing a better job of explaining is it
the
educational system do we need economists
to
make that more interesting or more clear
bring it home to people how
their household which they do understand
is something they can expand further
this is a serious problem
i only like to deal with fun problems
so it's not in the book
i'm i i'm sure that the uh the
responsibility has to partly fall
to uh journalists and i think that uh
journalists
uh like me and sebastian should be uh
on uh you know we should be writing for
usa today and we should be uh
on fox news a lot more often uh and we
should be paid more money
uh and um and then we could really make
this stuff uh
we could make this stuff interesting but
it's a tough problem
i have a broader question and that is
who is responsible for explaining
deficits to me
because i've never understood fiscal
policy and right now i'm teaching
phd macroeconomics
and my intuitions are that deficits
matter but when you look in the data
it's like trying to pull teeth and at a
level of you know three percent gdp
whatever
it doesn't seem to matter doesn't seem
to affect real interest rates or output
or investment
so i'm mystified so if someone asks me
to do the explaining
it's backwards i'm still waiting to be
explained too
well i have one question for you guys
before you summarize or
or punt on that um you you noticed in a
lot
are you particularly in the examples
that you tyler gave and
tim the examples in your book you you
point out
a lot of situations where
the provider of the service
discriminates between folks who want to
pay a lot for it and a little but
tyler you were talking about the drinks
at the restaurant and what have you
my question is um should we be worried
about that from a public policy
perspective or does it all
work out in the wash is that just a part
of competitive markets
or should we worry about government
interventions there
the and generally if uh
if the price discrimination helps to
open up new markets
uh this is a good thing i mean it's
if a company is supplying hiv
drugs to americans
at a premium price because frankly it's
worth it
um and they are forced to charge the
same price to everybody well
those drugs aren't going to go to africa
if on the other hand the company can
supply the drugs cheaply to africa and
be sure that
which is a big question be sure they're
not going to leak back into america well
that's just win-win
company makes more money africans get
treatments
the situation in the states is
completely unaffected and everybody is
better off
so i'm not i'm not that worried about
price discrimination there are examples
that i give in the book where it can it
can reduce welfare
the problem is that uh price
discrimination is is generally a sign of
market power
and when you have extreme examples of
price discrimination you often have
extreme market power
in the case of drug companies they are
given market power by the governments
the more i think about that the more i
think there must be a better way because
it doesn't seem to be working out too
well for various reasons
uh and i don't particularly blame the
drug companies for that um
so i'm worried about market power i
think there is a role for government in
dealing with market power
i'm not especially worried about price
discrimination
i would second that and maybe go a
little further i love price
discrimination
i think it almost always increases
output my big worry is that five years
from now you're going to take out your
cell phone
scan a price in the store and be told
it's cheaper somewhere else
and price discrimination will break down
and i think on that we could end up
being
worse off for that so my worries in the
opposite direction
here's a dilemma which i think this
raises which is um
okay supposing it's easier when you're
talking about
africa and the us on hiv drugs
and it follows from what you correctly
say that we should all want
um vigorously to inf to cut
crack down on the leakage of these hiv
drugs
from africa back into the u.s or
european markets because that will
destroy the ability to price
discriminate and that will
reduce utility for everybody but what
about um
when you've got canada and the us next
to each other
and americans are taking the bus to go
get cheap pharmaceuticals from canada
should we arrest people at the border
who are doing that
would this be because this is meddling
with price discrimination is that a bad
thing
um or is there some sense in which
um you know canadians are free riding
off
the u.s healthcare market which uh
forces the us consumer to bear more than
his fair share of the
uh of the research costs for the
industry and i think that's that is the
u.s canada example do you arrest people
on the border
where the question becomes tricky
i think that's a great question and
we're going to ask you folks back
uh to answer it uh i just wanted to ask
if any of you would like to say
a final word before we close my final
word is congratulations to tim
my final word is that most people buy
books and don't read them
read it you want to say anything
just very quickly i i wrote this book
to have fun i think economics is fun i
hope that people reading the book
are going to have fun and thanks to
bob sebastian and tyler i've had a lot
of fun
this lunch time and i hope you have too
thanks very much